hell's gum breasts - fitted this game is
the reason why you're all still virgins
y'all still a bunch of virgins get out
there get laid
Who am I kidding we're just gonna
playing oh but wait we got my gamer
glasses I can't see without oh wow
that's so much better
what up its your boy bay to the nether
I'm a popper capping all your asses
that's right Oh you look at my ass you
paid the consequences alright we go
sorry sorry I'm a pic boo mysterious new
character with a hat there's this Walter
White in another youniverse
so our fates and our paths cross once
again yes that's how people talk to your
man Oh
yeah that's definitely me
forget about it always gonna do he's
gonna say oh my god
I shipped them so much oh oh no no
oh man
how is that possible
also with the glasses we can see like
the other that must be it nothing what a
player need is nothing
also known as diamond glitters I think
with a the perfume Breanna Hansen is
derived from the memories or seenu's
quite appropriate for this what the [ __ ]
is this guy talking
will you quit calling me that I'm not a
pet or a cat Oh what you said Luca ok
I like his pants huh this guy's moving
she keeps saying that he know how to
make an entrance like who cares Don has
a soft spot for she shoots Saki from
Japan nice has he tried to get him to
make these for me and don't get a
twisted Bayonetta
stalking you this time it means
look I know you've got nothing but
secrets well that goes for anyone right
but if there's one thing I've learned in
my line of work it's what I've found you
you want about this time don't act dumb
with me you know the story better than
anyone I actually have no idea with the
tournament sages two clans that wielded
incredible power just 500 okay this is
good information because I don't know
lands of the overseer okay for us all
with the eyes of the world of course
power to govern light and darkness but
now I know that there really was an
overseer and this overseer is the one
who created the eyes of the world for
Humanity the same ones that the clans
held on to so hard still don't
understand the true God of the human
realm the god of chaos with God of chaos
from what my research is told me that
God used to live right here in military
ways to each realm of the Trinity of
realities it is Italian what a great
Italian this guy has gates of hell
listen I heard about John what how does
he know that wait was that squirrel in
our tits I took a liking to one of the
locals look I know this isn't the time
to chat let me see what I can find out
to help you just don't stick your nose
where it doesn't belong Trisha don't you
worry about my nose I can smell trouble
when I see it you just take care of
yourself oh my god he's so cool I love
him
man all right we are in Venice
hey what up its your boy bay to the NED
a alack your oranges [ __ ] you're injured
whoo
did I do something Oh God enemies the
guy has nipple stomach my favorite
cannon stomach
oh my god I'm back can you still see me
god oh god damn it
God [ __ ] you let's run up bust all your
way since torture attack bye bye [ __ ]
oh did you see that [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] amazing
so oh-oh-oh I'm 12 oh it's mr. squirrel
again why are we in Venice you know
usually gravity is boobs biggest enemy
but for Bayonetta it's like the opposite
it's like magnet I'm sorry you know I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry
hey what's wrong he has nightmares of
being inside her bra too much to handle
must nut fab I'm sorry I'm it's not
funny anymore I'm seeing too much I know
I'm sorry okay oh stop I can't
Oh evil twin
they resisted the urge well done
and here's tsunami well we're about to
get wet
hey Dodge Ted oh my god I'm in running
the wave oh that's so cool getting to
pantomime get into [ __ ] internment
parity oh my god this game is so cool
I've never seen a witch or a sink for
that matter something like that yeah
that was super cool dude you think I'm
just gonna tell you my secrets but I
don't even know whose side you're on
yeah you love it right I could be the
boy that's a big deal here it's seems I
mean no I got nothing else to say love
okay all right member it's time whatever
she heard that before
oh yeah this thing I'm holding in my
hand why yes I'm Chris I've got a party
and I have no intention of being late
did he just go right inside my bra what
up its your boy Baio to the [ __ ]
nadir pick up the hammer damn it I don't
think I did it
what's going on what's going on what's
going on that's dad what is that for
this guy why is he doing that
wait we can see his vision is he a
projector Oh
over
all right little guy time to spit the Sh
meal if you know what I mean what is
this was that necessary
we're not gonna talk about what just
happened I got the hammer i'ma run
upstairs i'ma run upstairs what up it's
always one of these okay so you jump on
them
yep got it and we're through
Oh God enemies ferret ants the prick
damn
oh they interrupted it it's that old
you've got right right
ride him ride him right now I'm riding
him whats good everyone
oh yeah what up its your boy pea to the
climax
that is an ugly ass [ __ ] toad man
I'll go I'm going with it all right Eric
hams Eric ABS he's gonna pop I love this
game let's continue
just getting breakdance oh no we're
supposed to go down here okay we're
going down here cool all right what up
its your boy B to the Nana there we go
squirrels out of the boobs you just
don't you don't just walk in the water
look over there
that's the Cathedral of Cascades it was
used for ritual worship of the mountain
inside there's a device I can build a
bridge to the heavens it'll take us half
way up from the lenten halfway an
exchange yes
right left seems something finally came
to mind little one while you're in the
remembering mood you wouldn't happen to
know where the entrance to Inferno is up
there would you
haha no you must be in some [ __ ] if
you're volunteering to go there let me
put it this way love once we get to the
mountain you'll get your choice of going
up or going down
cymbal Venter doesn't let you just stick
around and which way will you be going
me what's the matter little one yeah
what's that scared of what comes next
shut up oh just get me to the mountain
what is up with his to me well that's
that's the big thing what is up with
this guy he just gets randomly swallowed
by a tornado job boss
well it was bound to happen sooner or
later glamour more like bad grammar oh
my god that face that's the face of
Marzia watching me play this game
okay what we're surfing what oh this
game keeps getting better man how do
they come up with this we're surfing a
[ __ ] tornado oh gotta go through five
enemy whether they be in Malibu what
what the [ __ ] was that
oh it's on Oh
Mama's gonna smack your face Oh ballot
to the air where am I I'd up there am it
okay we're surfing some more
Jesus this is so crazy
oh my god where'd it come from Jesus oh
I see the hole I can see the hole guys
oh my god Queen slay what Wow
okay I guess we made it it looks like a
[ __ ] cutscene it's so amazing
time to Bay to Bay the [ __ ] outta a
that's the worst sentence I'm so sorry
stop that face that's so gross come on
fight me just [ __ ] bird
oh hey became red they're suppressing
the last [ __ ] Star Fox just meet
climax time oh we're getting there
we're getting to the gate [ __ ] that
[ __ ] up our backs
Oh
yeah I'm an adult
yeah why Simoes up that's it
jumbo juice for dinner boys
bro it's okay you [ __ ] up what
didn't grab is that so duly noted
it's so nice I don't know why it's so
nice to hear a character in the game
square that leaves us a girl I don't
know it you don't see it up oh my god
you asked stop laughing you [ __ ]
weirdo Jason it's the weirdest [ __ ]
laugh I ever heard where's the
jacksepticeye's I'm kidding it's getting
too much all right [ __ ] fallin Oh
what what do you come from that shit's
gonna hurt you can't fly into his boobs
to talk to a lady
hey teach me wait no time for this mate
where's the mountain no time for this
mate I am NOT an American trying to
speak and then British accent what the
hell was that
it's these days is it gonna work this
time I did
it's kind of like Azzaro meets Batman
meets spider-man oh you know when you
hear the squeak of leather that's when
they're pissed so much for a cat always
landing on his feet Cheshire
boy buttercream better but though where
do you go what
alright we're on the city streets well
then that took care of that I don't know
that [ __ ] was gonna happen I'm a crow
how do I do that well yep
Oh God that Big Ben Oh My Lord Jesus
come on alright we're gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of this guy real fast by a
breakdancing yeah why max
yes eat that [ __ ] up snack time honey
Oh
oh my lord well that took care of that
didn't it ChIP chip cheerio have a putt
cup of tea please I am NOT an American I
swear I am a British voice actor no time
no time I have to get your FEM ba
ba-da-da I'm a real voice actor he's
forgotten what's gonna happen we're
gonna fight him I know it oh [ __ ] that
was blood I was a guy with a giant thing
trying to kill you
how does he see with that thing nice
mask
how does he eat headed to that witch's
party not the best costume I've ever
seen but she doesn't seem like the bigge
type oh don't you see that where is she
yeah we sure so you are going to no
party quite the popular one isn't she
Sorry mate but I haven't the [ __ ]
slightest don't [ __ ] swear you're too
young
relationship she's seen her tats easier
[ __ ] indeed that's why his pants are so
big oh my god oh my god he took care of
them with a feather Jesus oh my lord
Oh
you're gonna go inside his bra maybe
Bayonetta's get a hairy look at that
scenery look at all that scenery - look
at that scenery oh boy what a scenery oh
[ __ ] it's so much damn I'm calling
timber oh that's gotta hurt [ __ ] bad
oh god he has ugly Resta that's why he
never showed his face god he might as
well be bald
sorry Michael okay you god damn your
hair I mean you've been doing it the
whole time Bayonetta nothing comes to
mind love sorry yeah who the [ __ ] are ya
maybe you've got something you'd like to
tell me love I'm not a fan of being
wrapped up in domestic disputes
trust me little one he's not my type
Oh dead drama drama drama drama whoa he
caught it himself
Jesus that's badass Jim so [ __ ] cool
no [ __ ] way he did that this is a
tough guy
thank you camera angle you're a lumen
sage what does that mean
it means it's strong that's what that
means I ran it it's been at a time is
that all you've got
oh oh smacking oh if you don't know
what's happening don't worry it's that I
know exactly what I'm doing
oh [ __ ] that can't be good
what is she doing being fabulous
okay [ __ ] summons
Parag early pet got it oh okay
everything changed apparently got it
this is as strong as a [ __ ] guys
oh my god it's so [ __ ] epic oh no oh
god no what okay we're summoning our
sexy demon girl thing
no I do not
Oh what the [ __ ] look at we're flying
now okay that's cool so epic this game
just keeps getting more and more and
more it's this crazy how do you keep up
I'm gonna get a seizure
that's not funny but seriously what the
[ __ ] how do you keep up how can they
keep getting more and more epic I don't
understand
it's [ __ ] impressive man oh yes let's
help our brows wake up - all right last
cutscene from
he's gonna professed don't worry that's
my specialty
[ __ ] yeah Oh no [ __ ] way
oh my god oh god yes
ah
oh my god I'm so done
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ man okay press
I'm gonna end this episode there if you
enjoyed watching please go ahead and
leave a like I really appreciate it
thank you so much
I'll see you tomorrow with another
episode as always
another agario